for decades people have been fascinated
by creatures of the past what did they
look like how did they move many
theories have been developed for many
species now researchers have turned
their attention to an ancient creature
called or Abati's which lived before the
dinosaurs roamed the earth using
cutting-edge techniques from computer
modeling to robotics they think they've
worked out how it moved bringing a
fossil back to life
[Music]
or Abati's lived around 280 million
years ago it was a time when vertebrates
were still quite new to walking on land
but its skeleton has been exquisitely
preserved to work out how it might have
moved researchers scanned the fossil in
three dimensions and used this to
construct a digital model of the or
Abati's skeleton this model could then
be animated sort of like a digital
marionette the marionette helped them
work out the range of motion for each
joint telling them how far or Abati's
could bend or stretch but it's unlikely
that or Abati's wall using its full
range of motion in every joint so they
needed to narrow it down a bit one way
to do that is to look at another fossil
not of our bodies itself but of its
tracks this fossil shows where an ore
Abati's specimen placed its feet long
ago as it rambled across the ground
programming the skeleton marionette to
walk inside the fossilized footsteps
narrowed down its movement further but
there are still many options for how an
ore Abati's could have made the
footprints to narrow it down more
researchers turn to living animals the
layout of or Abati's skeleton suggests
it would have had a sprawling gait like
modern-day lizards or salamanders so
researchers used x-ray video to film for
such creatures these data helped them
identify four key parameters which
define sprawling movement power balance
precision and something called ground
reactive force these four parameters
were used as the basis for a dynamic
simulation containing the skeleton
marionette and the footprints as the
weighting of these four traits is
adjusted the simulation spits out graphs
containing all the possible movement
combinations which fit the bill then the
researchers could pick through all the
outputs to find the most likely options
but there's still a catch computer
simulations can't account for everything
like the complexities of gravity there
are so many variables that it's really
hard to model them all in detail so
researchers went one step further to
validate their predictions in the real
world they built a robot this scale
sized robot was also modeled and added
to the dynamic simulation bringing with
it more physical constraints narrowing
down the options and combining all of
these different approaches they settled
on an answer the researchers think the
ORA Barty's moved with a relatively
upright gait and had more advanced
capabilities than expected for such an
early land dweller and that hints at a
different ecology a more mobile animal
may have been more adept at picking
through the landscape and perhaps be
able to travel further from water than
scientists had predicted the researchers
hope that some of their methods could
help reverse engineer the movement of
other fossilized animals and they've
made their model available for free
online click the link in the description
below to start your own investigation
into or Abati's movement
[Music]